you have to choose who you compare  yourself to so if you just start out as  something and it's brand new  and you compare yourself to someone  who's been doing it for 40 years  that's absurd like start a little bit  smaller or at least  recognize the fact that it took that  person 40 years to get there  and if you're not successful right away  that's completely normal  100 i would even use you as an example  you have  turned your life around through  nutrition that's a  big [ __ ] deal and i think a lot of  people could  benefit from that but if it's day one  for someone  and they start to adjust their nutrition  and whatever they're addressing  eczema or ibs or who knows what or  weight or whatever it is is not gone day  one they're not a failure  what was your goal for day one making it  through the day  did you make it through the day pat  yourself on the back a little bit